i have two clips that i'm going to play
for you here that are one very very
significant in terms of what it suggests
is happening legally in washington dc
right now and two one which is just
absolutely hilarious it's a sort of mic
drop moment related to matt gates and
his alleged uh child sex trafficking the
videos involve an individual named mark
short now mark short was former vice
president mike pence's former chief of
staff uh he we have now learned has been
um
brought under subpoena and testified
before a washington dc federal grand
jury investigating january 6. why is
this a big deal it's a big deal i'm not
quizzing you i'll tell you i don't ask
it rhetorically it's a big deal because
as the january sixth house committee has
been doing its work we've been wondering
aloud is the department of justice
investigating any or some or all of the
things that we've learned from the
january 6 committee or are they even
seriously investigating at a higher
level
um the events of january 6th we know
that there are hundreds of individual
defendants for their personal roles on
january 6th but there's a broader
question as to whether the bigger
picture of the way that trump and the
people around him incited the riots is
being investigated by merrick garland
the fact that mark short was under
subpoena and appeared before a federal
grand jury in washington dc at least
suggests that the answer is yes so the
funny clip is the second one let's look
at this first he didn't say much but
this is a major confirmation
i can confirm that i did receive a
subpoena for the federal grand jury and
i comply with that subpoena but under
advice of counsel i really can't say
much more than that
that was my only appearance before the
grand jury
i'm not going to comment what others on
the team have had to testify or not
regarding subpoenas and what they've
testified to this suggests it doesn't
prove but it certainly suggests and what
else might it mean it's hard to think of
something else this indicates
that the federal government the justice
department is now investigating january
6th at a bigger and higher level
than simply individuals who were at the
capitol on that day that's a major major
thing
also during an interview with cnn
short was asked about matt gates's
comments over the weekend
and short delivers an absolutely brutal
takedown of gates the look on cnn anchor
aaron burnett's face sort of says it all
here check this out
our america
is proudly
ultra magga not some low energy roadside
rhino safari
on that note let me just say what
everybody here knows
mike pence will never be president
nice guy
not a leader
mark
well i don't know if mike pence will run
for president 2024 but
i don't think matt gates would have an
impact on that in fact i'd be surprised
if he was still voting it's more likely
he'll be in prison for child sex
trafficking by 2024 and i'm actually
surprised that florida law enforcement
still allows him to speak to teenage
conferences like that so i'm not too
worried about matt gates thanks yeah
shocking that law enforcement even
allows matt gates against around people
under age 18. so listen
absolutely hilarious
perfectly delivered and in all
seriousness matt gates might get away
with absolutely
nothing happening to him and no
consequences whatsoever for the alleged
crimes that he has been involved in the
the question is what the hell is taking
so long i actually remember
when i first learned that matt gates was
under investigation for child sex
trafficking it was march of 2021 i
remember because it was my first trip
sort of like in the coved era i remember
exactly where i was i was about to go
out to the beach and i glanced at my
phone and saw gates is now under
investigation and it was the night that
gates appeared on tucker carlson's show
and gave that bizarre interview where he
was like tucker you've met the woman
supposedly i trafficked remember we went
to dinner and tucker was like i have no
memory of that whatsoever don't pull me
into this thing that was the start of it
that was now
16 months ago 16 months ago so is it is
it uh unusual that it can take this long
for investigations to be done no it's
not unusual
is it starting to get to the point where
it's reasonable to wonder what's going
on and are they even going to charge
gates with anything yes it is getting to
that point so good for mark short for
just saying what we're all thinking how
is this guy even still around allowed
around young girls absolutely well
delivered and it's all great and
everything but
it is not obvious to me
whatsoever that there are actually going
to be any consequences for matt gates
and of course these are alleged things
that he did if the evidence doesn't show
that he did them then he should not be
charged we this is not a show where i
demand people be charged for things they
didn't do
what we're aware of
is that matt gates alleged
co-conspirator
um certainly has acknowledged doing a
whole bunch of the stuff that he and
gates are accused of and so now it
starts to stretch
our credulity when we say well so the
other guy did all the stuff and he's
admitting it but we're supposed to
believe gates actually wasn't involved
in it when there's that
it's abundantly clear that they know
each other and that they were involved
in this stuff together starts to get
hard to believe but we will follow it
and hopefully mark short is correct